tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
inside one of the world's richest royal
families and the secret story of the
Arab Sheik infamous from drag racing
through the streets of Beverly Hills in
his Ferrari there the spoiled rich kids
of the Middle East now two Americans
coming forward in a lawsuit with tales
of prostitutes drug overdoses and the
sheiks demand to murder those who
betrayed him he told me once you go take
care of him what did that what did that
vein take care to kill him the Americans
tell their story tonight including the
videos they say show the Sheikh
harboring a u.s. digital justice wanted
in Detroit on murder charges it was no
surprise at all that he would be Harvard
in harboring a fugitive or were
associating with such an individual to
by no surprise whatsoever
plus our shoutout for the small town
Iowa newspaper editor whose paper almost
went out of business after it dared to
expose the shadowy activities of a local
police officer
the editors answer a GoFundMe page that
has now raised almost $100,000 if you
can't stand up for a vulnerable teenage
girl that I don't think you have any
business standing near a printing press
from the law and crime Network studios
in New York City's Herald Square this is
Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight the
secrets of a powerful Mideast royal
family laid bare in a lawsuit brought by
two Americans who work for them as they
traveled here in the US and overseas at
their palaces in the land they rule with
absolute unchallenged authority the
royal family in the Mideast country of
Qatar is the third richest family in the
world and few dare to challenge the
ruling leader the Emir or his relatives
as I found out when I approached him as
a correspondent at ABC News and was
later told
I could be imprisoned for doing just
that without permission but now two
Americans who worked for the royal
family in Qatar are taking them on in
this lawsuit filed in federal court in
Tampa in particular taking on the Emir's
brother Sheikh Khalid Al Thani alleged
to be a heavy drug user who ordered the
murders of two individuals in California
who he viewed as threats to his social
reputation and personal security one of
the men suing is Matthew petard of Tampa
hired by the shape to be chief of
security for his family seen here in a
promotional video for a security company
at the Sheikh fountain he thinks he's a
thug who's beyond a pre on reproach and
can go after and do whatever he wants
the other American suing the Sheikh is
Matthew a yen day of Los Angeles a
trained paramedic brought in by Matthew
petard the lawsuit says after the Sheikh
overdosed on opiates he had stopped
breathing his eyes rolled in the back of
his head how close was it how close did
he come to dying right there he had
stopped breathing
oh it's enough at first both men worked
for the Sheikh while he was in residence
in California his entourage taking up an
entire floor of the Beverly Wilshire
hotel in Beverly Hills there was there
was probably in his entourage maybe a
total you know give or take probably
about 50 to 60 people total all living
in the Beverly Wilshire hotel correct
and what was going on there who are
these people
servants hairdressers
security staff medical staff finance
people and he says some very unsavory
types to prostitutes and drug dealers so
drugs and hookers are part of a regular
routine at the Beverly Wilshire hotel
when he was in residence there yes sir
[Music]
the Sheikh was already well known to
police in Beverly Hills 2051 Manuel is
on the street almost got hit by one of
these cars and kids tonight tell me
they're scared to play on the streets
none of your business
he and his bodyguards at the time and
tried to act like tough guys with the
man who made the video get the caddy
here did you know that get out of my
pocket I'm not on your property I told
him that in America we have the free
press and we are allowed to film from
the sidewalk and he said F America and
threw a cigarette at me then the Sheikh
later claimed falsely that he had
diplomatic immunity to the outrage of
the Beverly Hills police chief do you
can't claim diplomatic immunity if you
don't have it and you can't use that as
an excuse to jeopardize the public or
commit crimes they're the spoiled rich
kids of the Middle East that's what
that's what I viewed how I saw it he
bragged about the incident oh yeah you
know it's racing you know through the
streets they've got me on the news ha ha
ha you know that kind of thing it was a
big joke to him yeah nothing was taken
seriously he felt that he can do
whatever you wanted and he did but
things got much more serious petard says
when the Sheikh gave him an order to
assassinate two individuals one man one
woman who he says the Sheikh suspected
we're going to reveal his secrets
this male had compromising photos of
Sheikh at one of these parties as well
as some video and some other things and
so he wanted you to kill him he told me
I want you to go take care of him what
did that what did that mean take care to
kill him instead petard says he gave the
man six thousand dollars to settle the
score
you're sure you understood what he was
saying they'll mistake here absolutely
the the female he told me to put two
behind her ear jokingly put his hand up
behind his behind his ear like this pop
pop in bury in the desert but Todd says
when he refused the Sheikh was furious
he said you're not a real marine you
disgust me get out of my sight and a
problem I got up and left that look the
sweet but the pay was good at $100,000 a
year and both men traveled with the
Sheikh back to Qatar as he moved into
his palace in the capital city of Doha
the to travel with him wherever he went
this video was shot by Allende in the
sheiks police motorcade to the country's
yearly national day celebration and we
were escorted by law enforcement down to
where the royal family sat where he
could go in the presence of Tamim the
Emir it was an experience you know
you're in a motorcade with a royal
family member you're seeing these
amazing homes properties vehicles you
name it and anything that the man wanted
you either had or he'd get it the sheiks
passion appears to be auto racing again
they took this video inside the sheiks
auto warehouse showing just some of what
he says is an astounding collection of
expensive vehicles some costing in the
millions of dollars bugatti chiron
the version he had was three and a half
million or so and the Sheikh has his own
race car track and racing team in Qatar
a Yundi says among those he regularly
saw with the Sheikh at the track was a
man he later learned was a fugitive from
American justice this man mo ITAT wanted
on a murder charge in Detroit involving
an illegal drag race that killed a
mother and her two children in 2001 a
tat was featured on an edition of
America's Most Wanted every single time
we would go the racetrack he was there
and he was always either on the drag
strip or communicating with Sheikh
Khalid Sheikh all its criminal behavior
it was no surprise at
that he would be harboring harboring a
fugitive or were associating with such
an individual to by no surprise
whatsoever it wasn't long the two men
say before they grew tired of the Sheikh
and his shady associations and continued
they say drug use while in Qatar but
petard says the Sheikh threatened to
kill him if he left calling him disloyal
he called me on the phone and basically
said you backstabbing piece of how can I
cuss on this you can bleep it out you
backstabbing piece of shit I'm gonna
fucking kill you
bury you in the desert to kill your
family but ours says he sought help from
the US Embassy in Qatar to flee the
country before the Sheikh could get to
him that an idle threat or you think he
really meant that I I think he meant it
in the case of Ind
he says the Sheikh refused to let him
leave his compound so he had to try to
escape climbing over this 14 to 18 foot
wall I chanced it because I felt that
was a better alternative than being held
against my will I'm not gonna be a
prisoner to this man and I jumped
instant pain to the left side of my body
fell the rounds again they says he broke
his leg and guards caught him and
dragged him back inside the compound and
then ordered him to go to the sheiks
bedroom basically I've broken you you
know you can't if I don't want you to
and that's all he wanted to know is you
can't well you wanted me to no rather it
was you can't go unless I say you can go
the Sheikh continues to live a protected
life in Qatar his two former employees
say he has started his own security
consulting business which produced this
corporate promotion video
two men say he continues to recruit
other Americans to work for him and they
want to sound the alarm I know for a
fact I'm not the only American that was
held against my will he can do whatever
he wants and the public needs to know
that this man is corrupt and as soon as
you get over to where he's the law of
the land he can do whatever he wants
over the last few weeks we have reached
out repeatedly to their Qatar embassy
here in the US for comment on the
lawsuit but none of our calls or
messages were returned but joining us
now is Rebecca cos 2theta the lawyer
representing the two Mathews petard in
Ind thanks for being here this afternoon
you're a former federal prosecutor but
the allegations in this case if this
losses are probably as explosive as
anything you've worked on it for the
Department of Justice I imagine it is it
is as exciting as when I was a
prosecutor absolutely and in some ways
marks that different country different
region and you were telling me in fact
that there are suspicions that people
might be following you trying to
intimidate you that's correct
as soon as we were able to serve cage
holding I had tinted out cars following
me following my family their president
outside our home they follow me on the
way to taking my children to school to
target you know daily activities as soon
as we had good service these people
appeared and they're still following me
Rebecca costanera question for you from
our control room from executive producer
Rhonda Schwartz Rhonda so what happens
next the Sheikh is in Qatar probably
very well protected how does the case go
forward well a couple days ago we filed
a motion to amend the complaint to
include his racing car company they
probably should have been included in
the original complaint but we were able
to obtain additional additional evidence
and we recently filed for a motion to
amend so they have now been added we're
waiting for the ruling on that judgment
and then now we proceed in the lawsuit
against his racing car company in the
future we'll see what
happens but so far like us you haven't
heard back from them at all they haven't
responded to this explosive lawsuit
other than their response with having
people follow me now no one has the
contacted us and is he an absolute
authority does he have any kind of
immunity in this country he does not not
here in the United States he did not
when he stated he did and he does not
know we checked with the Detroit police
about the mowett at the man who was seen
at the racetrack there and they say the
warrant for his arrest is still
outstanding and in the hands of the FBI
are they aware of what your clients have
discovered the federal law enforcement
investigation authorities in our country
have knowledge of this case yes and they
know who he deals with and they know
what's contained in our complaint and
what my client state yes and has he
broken the laws in this country in your
view with the supposed murder plots and
the usual use of drugs and prostitutes
at the Beverly Wilshire hotel oh
absolutely
you if you know as a as a prior
prosecutor or as a plaintiff's attorney
now criminal activity abounds in this
lawsuit and as well as what's in our
civil complaint it's kind of like pick
your action s so what you there's so
many colors to this lawsuit yes
absolutely and still more to come new
allegations yes new ones we just again
filed a motion to amend the complaint
against his race car company all right
well Rebecca Kosta thank you for joining
us tonight and thanks to your two
clients the two Matthews a petard and
IND for sharing their story with us we
appreciate it
thank you next up the intrigue and
conspiracy theory surrounding the deaths
of two high-profile federal prisoners
just got a lot more mysterious
tonight mystery and intrigue as new
developments are stoking conspiracy
theories surrounding two very
high-profile criminals who were being
held in federal prisons it was one year
ago that mafia boss an FBI informant
Whitey Bulger was murdered just hours
after he was transferred to a new prison
in West Virginia a prison where a number
of the inmates believed they'd been put
there by Bulger known to them as the
white rat the FBI said it would conduct
a full investigation of the Bulger death
but as of this broadcast no one has been
charged with his murder and the
Department of Justice has yet to explain
how he ended up in the general
population of a prison full of his
enemies and now there are new questions
about what happened to Jeffrey Epstein
the accused sex trafficker found dead in
his cell in a New York federal facility
officially his death was ruled a suicide
but now one of the country's most
respected medical examiner's dr. Michael
Baden says he thinks the injuries he saw
during the autopsy are more consistent
with a homicide that a suicide Bawden
appeared with me and his wife and law
and crime anchor Linda Kennedy to
describe the three broken bones he found
in Epstein's throat does that make it
impossible that it was a suicide
not impossible because although we've
never seen I've never seen in 50 years
and working on lots of suicidal hangings
for the most common way people commit
suicide in prison they don't have other
means to do it is that have one fracture
is unusual tap two is rare I have never
seen three fractures in a suicide 15
years you've never seen three fractures
in a suicide it would indicate that it's
a homicide then well that would but we
don't have all the information for
example is the FBI looking into the
corrupted video that wasn't working
allegedly when this when Epstein died
and maybe they found things if they
found something that shows Epstein
hanging himself up that would be pap
more powerful evidence the work of dr.
Baden who was hired by Epstein's brother
mark will no doubt fuel the conspiracy
theories that his brother was murdered
by people who wanted to keep him quiet
about his powerful friends and the
underage girls he recruited as sex
slaves up next our shout out for the
newspaper editor in Iowa whose reporting
about a local police officer resulted in
a big lawsuit that threatened to put him
and his paper out of business back now
with our shout out tonight for the owner
and editor of a small-town newspaper in
Iowa who had to put the future of his
paper on the line after he published a
completely true news story that even so
ended up in an expensive lawsuit but as
Douglas burns is about to tell us that's
what all too often investigative
journalism is all about the community is
about 10,000 people we we we cover a
Carol and a pretty broad surrounding
area so we try to be neither the common
scold or the blind booster the Carol
Times Herald in Carroll Iowa was founded
by Douglas burns grandfather some 90
years ago Burns is the infant in this
photo and the pictures on his editor's
wall tell a story of a local newspaper
with great ambitions
this was burns in the Oval Office after
an interview with President Obama with
the advent of the the Trump
administration and some of the fake news
tropes is appreciated and we do a lot of
it but the cost of doing those stories
can be high as Burns discovered in a
story about this Carroll Police Officer
Jacob Smith that began with the tip that
Smith was having a sexual relationship
with a teenage girl in Iowa the age of
consent is 16 so there there was nothing
criminal with that relationship but we
thought was the kind of involvement in
activity by a police officer that the
community should know about and that you
know most most parents would
buh-bye and find that kind of would find
it very concerning so we worked on the
story if you've read it it's it's it's
thoroughly reported and the reporter
that wrote it is very experienced the we
we didn't you know we we vetted it as
closely and as carefully as any Brian as
any story that that we've ever published
officer Smith resigned even before the
story was published and then filed a
lawsuit against the Times Herald so I
had never been sued before and I
wouldn't suggest people add it to their
bucket list in the lawsuit Smith alleged
his reputation has been destroyed his
character and integrity forever
castigated in the public eye and his
employability as a law officer severely
damaged if not totally ruined and when
you began your defense did you consider
a retraction or correction to get rid of
the lawsuit we did not because we felt
that we had the story and that if we
would if we would surrender on this
Brian that it would have a chilling
effect on not just other media but
particularly other small media in Iowa
uh that that we you know if we if we
caved on it for financial expediency
which I was given an opportunity to do
that in the end the judge dismissed the
case finding the article at issue is
accurate and true and the underlying
facts are undisputed
buttburn says it took a year and more
than $100,000 in legal fees to get that
result that I knew full well that had we
lost the case that my career would have
been over then and you know we would
have had to you know sell the paper then
for either financial reasons or
credibility reasons and now Byrne says
he's been forced to ask for outside
financial help in an unusual move
posting a GoFundMe page seeking $140,000
to cover all the expenses that came out
of the lawsuit if if you can't stand up
for a vulnerable teenage girl that I
don't think you have any business
standing near a printing press so this
was the
Hill you're willing to die on and you
know I've been even in doing this
interview now and doing this
conversation for him being involved in
these conversations you know I have
trepidation that that because of the
spotlight being drawn on this case again
that uh you know it could it could still
hurt us at this point any regrets at all
about the decision you made to run the
story and to stand up to the lawsuit I
don't think I got to live with myself if
I you know if we hadn't hadn't pursued
hadn't pursued the story it was the
right thing to do this is why local
ownership matters because this is this
is my community I live here I'm on the
Library Foundation I helped start the
Carroll High School Foundation cuz I
care deeply about this town and I don't
want this kind of behavior occurring
here as of this week the GoFundMe page
has received more than ninety six
thousand dollars enough to keep going
but certainly not with any frills I my
salary right now is under thirty
thousand dollars a year to keep the
paper going so there's there's not gonna
be any trips in the future any you're
not gonna have to come out here and do
an investigative piece about how the
money's being used because it's it's
going right back into into journalism
and so our shout out to Doug Burns and
all the great reporters and his Carol
times Harold I started my professional
career as a reporter in Iowa and was
fortunate to have a number of editors
who just like Doug Burns valued
integrity and courage over profits
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
and next week